If I could meet me when I was 16,
I think the first thing that I would say
is that it is so tempting to do something
for somebody to get them to like you.
Don't.
Really be mindful that you are so wise right now
because of all the things that you don't know.
So just, really before somebody
asks you to do something,
really take time to think about
whether or not it's going to be good for you,
that if, after you do it, you're going to go,
"Oh, I'm so glad I did that!
That was so good for me,
that was so wonderful."
You know, whether that's, whatever it is,
whether it's eating something,
drinking something,
being with somebody,
taking a job,
whatever it is,
just really check into the wisdom
that you already have
to see how you're going to feel after you to do it.
That's the first thing.
And the second thing,
I think there's loads,
but the second thing is jealousy.
Jealousy is a wonderful engine.
When you have it,
really, really take it in
and ask yourself,
"Ooh, I'm really jealous of so-and-so.
What is it I'm jealous about?
What is it that they have that I want?"
And then trust that you already have it
and act as if you do,
and if you don't,
if you really feel,
"Ooh, I don't have that thing or that attribute,"
then trust that somewhere you have some quality
that resembles that and let it grow in you.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.